bueno es una cita muy importante aunque
con grandes ausencias raúl no está mente
particularmente perdón la de el
presidente chino y del presidente ruso
que no vienen justamente a roma' por el
cob y 19 temas a tratar el clima de
hecho es muy importante también porque
de luego empieza la con 26 en glasgow
por eso también es importante la
presencia aquí del presidente de los
eeuu lo importante es aumentar la
ambición de los países raúl porque ya se
ha visto que si no se aumenta esa
ambición no vamos a llegar nunca a lo
que se acordó en parís en el año 2015
otro tema importante la crisis sanitaria
cómo ser más solidarios en los países
ricos más de un 60 por ciento de la
población ha recibido dos dosis sin
embargo esa cifra baja a un 4 por ciento
cuando hablamos de los países pobres y
el tercer punto a tratar es cómo superar
la crisis económica derivada de la
crisis sanitaria y obviamente también
ser solidarios con los países pobres
sobre todo el presidente de argentina
alberto fernández viene con una
propuesta de reestructurar la deuda de
los países pobres afectados por la
crisis sanitaria y también la crisis
económica deriva